you guys need to stay in the city to
meet me and then we're going on from
going to rob Jack hi there sir here just
get run over
now they are hey that's a bit yeah
[Laughter]
maybe getting your car get my coat away
I wouldn't look at you let me look at
you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah nice I got me
brave yeah what breath
yes didn't know what the [ __ ] is put all
right just esis Christ
Kenny oh yeah I'm sure
ha ha ha bring a homeless person look at
sexy lady over here hey girl hey girl
I'm doing look I'm trying to pick up
this phone honey hang on a second look
that bad but donk a donk
crap I like your best gear
very nice Jake sit here what it is ICBM
chief yang hey Garrett come back here
nobody but that dude right there who's
that guy who are you look at that nice
bug girl that's right it's a girl right
oh thanks Jack are you shooting me no
shoot me [ __ ]
oh nice I surrender hey let's be friends
wait wait wait wait wait wait please the
food here we go guys oh there's the
police that that cool I'm committed how
is it I'm cool I'm committed I'm cool
yeah that's right I'm cool I'm in the
Prius and we expect a thing ha ha no one
just [ __ ] in a Prius Wow
ah touch it touch the thing it's for
four seconds Oh - hi
round the d-bag round the d-pad you're a
diva yeah watch you in your later
[Applause]
I got this haha my face yeah yes yeah
yes Luffy Edgar I found on the beach I
got a hit gotta put your helmet on
safety first
that can be ride with me yes I don't
know it Wow
ah hey I know what happens at a bonfire
herpes that's what happens
herpes hey yeah yeah how'd you gotten
hurt he's the one that had the herpes
jack with you oh there's party herpes
hey hey what watch watch you throw main
gotta go to Walmart and get some
biscuits uh-oh man I need some
Cheboksary girl it was gonna be so good
let me Sophie sweet - biscuits when we
get one chance this is a grill Jase oh
yeah yeah all right you can have it
I'm your uber hey yeah oh yeah I'm outta
here Wow
well so Heckman's candidate I'm Jay Baer
Oh
ah they should go down yes go to go to
go to go to Hangang for the Janet I'm
going for the chance to clean up thanks
to me you let a tank my weight now where
I got the ocean witness fee instead we
get it get it get it yeah yeah okay I
got like an Aldi thing you can get in
mind
oh my [ __ ] card exploded
[ __ ] ass I swear to God if I
explode now you shut up what the [ __ ] is
that tree doing there I found myself a
jet I finished through your weapons and
that day is to shoot them Oh keep
[ __ ] shooting me get in get it I
swipe you nicked a man PCP oh my god oh
my god dude dude oh oh right
Oh shave not over ha ha what's that [ __ ]
was that [ __ ] ice the [ __ ] hi
scan just oh god I'm stuck
No